les dieux de l'olympe existe vraiment il
leur arrive de concevoir avec des
humains des enfants qu'on appelle les
sangs mêlés
nous ressemblons presque à n'importe qui
à quelques détails près
nous vivons dans le seul endroit au
monde où les gens comme nous sont en
sécurité
mais plus pour longtemps qu'est ce que
c'est que ça entre tu trouveras l'oracle
chronos au pouvoir si maléfique
reviendra pour exercer sa vengeance
entre l'olympe
la seule chose qui ait le pouvoir de
sauver notre camp et la toison d'or
c'est une mauvaise idée tu sais même pas
ce que j'allais dire tu allais dire que
tu vas retrouver la toison d'or
il allait dire qu'on y va tous les trois
c'est le char de la nation dirait un
taxi new yorkais c'est pareil
et non
nous ressusciterons chronos et les dieux
de l'olympe connaître en a marre on
trouvera la toison
dis moi que c'est pas des requins c'est
pas des requins